so
do you have a specific diet-wise stuff
you like
so you know i've recently another
ridiculous sounding thing but it makes
me feel
really good it's very low carbs so
you know keto or even carnivore it
sounds ridiculous
it doesn't make any sense but it makes
me feel really good even for performance
is rogan has an influence you know he's
a no carnivore diet i was influenced
actually by people
yeah there's i'll tell you where because
i was doing it before he was doing it
uh is there's it was uh popular in the
endurance athlete community
where it was fat adapted athletes it's
people who
insane people who run 50 miles 100 miles
they figured out that they could fuel
their body by
with fat they can go to fat as a source
of energy as opposed to carbs
so and i remember
hoping that i'll be able to learn how to
run 50 miles and so on
i've never done more than 22 but
it i i just remember switching away from
carbs
and feeling really liberated
like i wasn't thinking about food as
much i'm able to eat once a day
and feel really good i mean i think
every everybody's body is different
but i think carbs make me lazy
maybe it's because uh yeah it's the
crash but also just uh psychologically
something um
it uh it forces me to also think about
food too much like it starts becoming
you know art just like you said our
society is so much about food there's so
many
so much advertisement and so much of our
social life is about food
and so it's very easy to live life
like live day to day thinking when is
the next meal
like what am i gonna eat for lunch what
am i gonna eat for dinner what am i
gonna eat for breakfast
and uh if you're not careful that's
gonna get in the way of you doing
cool for like
liberating yourself and thinking like
what am i actually passionate about in
this life
like creating and forgetting to eat
those kinds of things
and still being able to fuel your body i
don't know
it's been fascinating to to figure out
like later in life that carbs aren't
necessary to function well
it's it makes me think like we don't
know anything about nutrition
that's right you know
personally i don't think i
could have a diet without carbs i love
chocolate too much
for me eating it's a it's a pleasure of
life i love my carbs i love my sugar
however if you talk about that i don't
have a specific diet
but recently i what i'm trying to do is
the days that i do not work out i only
eat
once that's kind of my rules
plus i try to respect sixteen eight and
do my
three day fast four time a year
and but the rest of the thing i i i
i i let myself lose because i i don't
think i would be happy if i
if i uh if i if i don't give myself the
the the right to to eat for me
personally i love to eat so much
next and um you talk about uh diet
carnivore diet it's very interesting
because i
i a few years ago i went to
africa in masai mara and
it's a tribe in uh in in east africa
and um i went to visit them i did a
safari
and i talked to them and these guys they
their diet is 99
carnivore they they that's crazy and you
should see they're very beautiful people
like shredded like
yeah some people would say oh it's
genetic i'm like yeah maybe it's genetic
but
i mean and think about the eskimos also
that like most of their diet is
on on fish right they so
i believe it can be done you know like i
believe it can be done
like an exclusive carnivore diet and i
i think i'm gonna try it pretty soon
just to have the experience
you know to see how it feels like where
you're gonna hang out with joe
be careful bringing it up because he'll
convince you to uh forever switch to
carnivore definitely he loves it
i mean but just like you i think he
loves
food so he's he can't ever stay on
carnivore
it was funny because we went to an
italian restaurant together and
i still only eat meat like i love
i love the constraints of discipline
that's that's partially why i like
carnivore i like saying no to food that
is delicious
[Laughter]
but part of the problem is that i don't
know how to moderate you said chocolate
i don't know how to have one chocolate
is that something you're able to do have
like
in moderation no it's when it when i
have an opportunity i do it i don't
have any i'm an extremist person alex i
i
that's the thing when i when i have a
chance i
i like i just eat i go too much and
that's what i like about my life you
know that's what i
like about fasting because probably if
i would not have discovered fasting
eating chocolate would give me cramps
and and all
sorts of problems yeah because people on
circulitis
normally they cannot eat chocolate they
cannot drink alcohol but i believe
because i'm fasting that's the reason
why i'm
i'm medication medicine medication free
i can eat whatever i want whenever i
want but i have to do that that fasting
you know and now it becomes to it became
to a point that it's no longer
hard for me it's it's like normal i
don't even force myself
yeah i don't it's easy you know what i
mean
some of my friend thinks i'm think i'm
i'm insane you know
but i tell them it's like with when you
get used to it it becomes like an
abbot and i'm and i know that
hunter-gatherer
like our ancestor did not eat three
times a day
it's it's it's not true they
they ate when they they could and when
they eat they
they they feed themselves as much as
they can until that because the next
time because they didn't know when they
did they could eat again right so it's
uh
i think that's how we're we're built you
know to to
to have this similar lifestyle
you